Pro Football Hall of Fame finalist once
again one of my favorite people on the
planet his San Francisco 49ers he's the
general manager that team they're the
one seed taking on the Vikings in front
of the home crowd to kick-off the
divisional playoff weekend on Saturday
on NBC he is John Lynch how are you John
I'm doing great rich it's uh it's crazy
as I'm just listening to you talk and
that gentleman who was a Seahawks fan
and and the fact that we're the one seat
by 6 inches crazy you got 13 and threes
and then amazingly did six inches that
decides whether we're a 1 or a 5 I guess
so it's kind of your season that's kind
of your season John I mean your team
having lost uh you never got blown out
it was all they were all tight games
your team is competitive your team is
tough your team is nasty your team is is
tested as well from this year despite
obviously having a bunch of people not
in the playoffs previous to this year a
lot of folks in the team what is it like
though for you somebody who's played in
playoff games played in big-time games
won a championship what is it like for
you though to be a GM in the situation
it's it's a combination of you know this
is this is why I made the leap and this
is why you do it to to try to build a
team that can compete for championships
and be in a position like this and then
it's a you know something I continue to
deal with in this role is is the
helpless feeling that there's nothing I
can do right now and you know from my
standpoint kind of haze in the barn so
just support these guys but the coolest
thing Rich's got so much confidence in
this team for no other reason other than
then they've earned it all year long
they've just been they've been up to
every test and I think when you talk
about being tested
you know they've I don't know if I've
ever been involved in a season where you
just you experienced the variety of
things and and the team has come through
in a variety of ways you know whether it
be you know winning 9-0 and the rain and
DC or shootout in in New Orleans and and
you know went in with a dominant defense
or went in with a run offense or a pass
offense and it's a testament to the
mettle of this group I think it's also a
testament to
Kyle Shanahan his leadership and his
staff they've done a tremendous job kind
of putting together a group of really
talented and and and young men that have
a lot of high character and and so hats
off to all them they deserve the credit
let's however I know there's no I in
John or Lynch but let me let me let me
say then you you helped build this team
- John so how is this in the mold of
what you envisioned or what you embodied
as a player yeah I think all of us are
product of our experiences and and so
you know as you start to put put this
thing together you know I don't think
it's brain surgery he you look at each
other Kyle and I and okay we got to find
our quarterback and we had a very
fortuitous and and Jimmy Garoppolo came
our way and we saw him go to work in
that first year and then had a great
deal belief that not only did he change
our team but also that the room for
improvement was immense and and that was
going to come with experience
unfortunately that got cut short last
year but this year he got the experience
a whole year and I think really shines
but then I think I think when I think of
this team that the hallmark is you know
that coupled with building our deal I
mean we wanted to build a defensive
front that was one that you were going
to have to to be reckoned with each and
every week and if you didn't you know
give them the proper attention they were
going to wreak havoc and and so I think
we built the team in that mold and we
also had ideas and in terms of the type
of spirit we wanted on this team we
wanted guys that were passionate
competitive you know dependable all
those things that that you know turns
into the character of your team and and
so I think that's how this team was
built and a lot of people played a role
in it and I think it's through through
you know both coaching staff and
personnel staff working together that
you really hone in on the right guys
we've made plenty of mistakes but you
know or fortunately we've picked them
some players that really love the game
and our and are pretty talented and when
you put that together you've got a
you've got a chance you know and John
Lynch here on the Rich Eisen show one
last question on this about how a team
gets put together and certainly you be
brought in Shannon was already there
they reached out to you took you out of
the booth from Fox and you said yeah I
want to do this and how it all works
being put together
it just seems every single dude on
offense on offense is just a big tall
physical beast that is running slashing
at the most difficult angle for the
defense to grasp okay and then they're
running downhill a million miles an hour
causing you to make a business decision
on the other end that's what it looks
like to me John and is that some way
that you put together like that guy
would fit perfectly here Kyle or Kyle's
like hey John that guy would guy would
fit perfectly here in the offense I'm
cooking up here how does it yeah I like
hearing that
but I think I think that's one of the
reasons you know why why you would leave
a booth I wasn't going to do this just
for any place and you know had a had a
opportunity to be at a place that was
just an iconic franchise and the 49ers
had fallen upon some hard times but then
the opportunity was to work with a guy
that I thought could not just be good
but could be special in in Kyle Shanahan
and and so I think his ability and you
know one of the things that was
recognizable as we started to have
conversations even when I was in
broadcasting and production meetings
with him just how well he knew his
offense how well he knew his personnel
how well he knew exactly what he was
looking for at each position and not
only him he had a whole staff that came
with him that had just a lot of
knowledge even though they were young
guys they had been in the system for a
long time and and they live it they
breathe it and they you know that's
that's what you have to do you have to
communicate and say what exactly are we
looking for and so there were some
hallmarks and some things we both agreed
on and one of the things I failed to
mention right at the start we you know
one of the key components we wanted to
be a fast team and you look at our
running backs for instance they're all
four three guys I mean and that's that's
awesome and they can Beach in a variety
of ways but Kyle does such a tremendous
job of getting all these athletes that
we have in space but we get out and run
and and he puts them in space and puts
them in great positions to make plays
Jimmy's done a great job distributing
and
the football and and those guys have
done a great job now we we have a really
big challenge with the Vikings and and
their defense
Zeb's been a phenomenal coach in this
league for a long time on that side of
the ball they've got a group that's got
great continuity reminds me a little bit
in terms of the continuity aspect of our
Tampa defenses we had all played
together so long he kind of know exactly
what someone's thinking without even
verbalizing it and you see that from the
Vikings so it's a big challenge for us
John Lynch your general manager of the
49ers a day before taking on the Vikings
in the divisional round and also the
38th anniversary of the catch was today
38 years ago today Montana through to
Clark in the back of that end zone Wow
John it's my job to Brooklyn perspective
that's my job looking back in my office
right when I write when I I got here I
bought at an auction I said if I'm gonna
be here I gotta have that in my office
so I bought a Dwight Clark sign ball and
he kind of stenciled out the play right
there so I'm looking at January 10th
1982 the moment where Clark caught the
ball in the back of the endzone and so
many people obviously in 49 or lower say
that's the moment where it all kind of
start or at least the tide turned when
the Cowboys were no longer the the NFC
team to beat it was Montana and the rest
of the team and and I think if I'm not
mistaken the old saloon riding and the
colors of the team are being at put in
the end zone in Santa Clara like from
that the same exact font are you
involved in that sort of stuff to her
that's that's down below the flow chart
I see it like everybody else on on the
Twitter in the internet I see those
pictures it looks good it looks great it
is old school so let's quickly get into
I guess the nuts and bolts of who's
coming back you got a whole bunch of
injured players that have a shot to come
back you're gonna actually maybe take a
couple off I are today and make it
official can you tell me about the
health of some of your players coming
back for this game yeah one of the added
bonuses of you know that number one seed
and having that buy is that you know we
had some extra time and I think that
accomplished a couple things number one
we've had some key players that have
been her
starting with Tchaikovsky tarde he's
been out with some broken ribs here for
for some weeks and and you know this
this time allowed kawaski to get back on
the field and practice and he'll be
ready to play quan alexander will will
be activated today and will play a role
in tomorrow's game we're really excited
about that he was a huge free agent
acquisition for us brings energy but
more more importantly just brings great
football to the field for us and then
very hopeful that we'll have D Ford I
think Ford's the one that will go right
down to game time hamstrings can be
really tricky he's done a tremendous job
rehabbing it you know you have to be so
judicious with those and and it's really
one of those that will come down to
right before the game and how he's
feeling and we're hopeful because he
changes us when we're out there we've
we've been dominant as a deal I and
Wendy has played and we've been really
good otherwise and and we're comfortable
playing if we don't have him but you
know he does right raised it an another
level it really becomes a picture poison
are you gonna are you gonna double when
he's out there so we're hopeful that we
have him and in some form or fashion but
all that kind of will play out here in
the next 24 hours yeah and you know
Jimmy G it's his first rodeo starting in
a playoff game he's I think he took the
victory formation in an AFC Championship
game against the Colts a couple years
ago but that's it how do you and Kyle
get him I guess any way shape or form
mentally ready for what might come
obviously the the real experience you
can't you can't replicate it but it is
obvious is it's it's right there it's
it's your quarterback German laying out
what do you what are your thoughts on
that situation John Lynch yeah well you
know I think the thing about experience
there's nothing you can do about it
except just go do it and and that the
nice thing I guess with Jimmy is that
he's been there before
not as the starter but he I think you
said to me you know when I first played
playoff football that because you live
in the moment so much the idea that you
lose you go home the finality of it the
the importance of every snap doesn't
really hit you until you've experienced
either a win or loss in in the in the
playoffs but Jimmy I think has been on T
and so that will help but otherwise I
think just keep doing what you've done
all year I think it's one of Jimmy's
great strengths he's got an ability in
the biggest moment to play his best and
you know in adverse conditions playing
his best and that's something he's done
all year long as I said he understands
and we understand the challenge we're
playing a really good team with a really
good defense but we're pretty confident
about what we bring to the table and
Jimmy should be he's done a tremendous
job all year he's got a coach who's
gonna put him in great positions but I
think the thing I love about Jimmy the
most is he could really care less if we
ran the ball 50 times and found a way to
win he'd be happy if he threw it 50
times and found a way to win he's just
about winning and that's what we love
about him
okay two last things for you John
number one pass interference being
reviewable we've discussed it before I
know you put your hat on as a former
player and a rightful Pro Football Hall
of Famer and we'll get to that in a
second
but you're a general manager who also
watched a moment occur in the end zone
in game 256 we're sure look like there
are something going on in the end zone
nothing got stopped fully to review and
change it a if you go when you go to the
owners meeting in in March what will you
say when you may be asked your thoughts
on whether we should continue doing what
we've done the last year well I I think
people have to remember I know the
lesson coach Dungy actually taught me
when he when you look at these rules
always go back to where you know what
what precipitated the move to to have
those rules in place and I think the the
idea was that we got a we got to prevent
what happened in New Orleans last year
the clearest and obvious of things now
the problem is you know we're watching
NBC or Fox and you've got thirty two
camera angles and you slow it down to
the nth degree
everything looks like pass interference
so you know you take that play up in
Seattle well you know was there contact
absolutely but you know if any
maybe you'd call it on offense and on
defense and so that's why I think in my
opinion if you and it's hard to do
because everybody sits there and
whatever way they they want to see it
they can say there was contact but I
think let you know in my mind you try to
prevent the clearest and the obvious of
things from from effect in the outcome
of a game but if you start trying to
adjudicate every every little bit of
contact and turning over things I think
the hardest part is in this first year
that's been such a transition and really
thinking that it's a moving target and
not knowing I mean you figure like if
you're in the game you should have a
good understanding of what is and isn't
and I think that's been tough and I
don't blame anyone for it it's a new
thing but the stakes are really high so
it's it's a little nerve-racking going
into games and I think the best way to
do it and what we talked about play with
great technique when you play with great
technique you don't put yourself in
those those adverse positions and and if
you can do that that's you focus on what
you can control and that's where our
focus is right now so would you shut its
here if they said it's one and done if
that's one and done if the rule of pass
interference being reviewable is like
let's not do it anymore
would you share I wouldn't share alright
John look I'll say it you don't have to
react but you can if you wish you're a
Hall of Famer man and I'm not just
saying that because I've known you a
long time and I'm an eye full disclosure
I I call you a friend I consider you a
friend and you deserve it Sapp tells me
all the time
Hammond Brooks their job was to make
sure you got everything in that defense
to clean it up and be the back end of
that defense you have a ring nine Pro
Bowls a bunch of all-pro seasons first
and second team Bart Starr Man of the
Year award on top of all of it you
deserve to get in there's it's your
seventh time on the finalist list and I
hope you hear your name Super Bowl
weekend John but I certainly appreciate
that I you know I've been blessed this
games been so good to me and my family
and and you know the opportunity to play
with guys like
derreck Brooks and Warren staff in Champ
Bailey and all those great teammates and
and there's so many more that aren't in
the Hall of Fame that were just as
important to me you know how blessed was
I and and you know I just pinched myself
that people say does it get frustrating
sure it does kind of get teased every
year but you know what sevens been a
pretty good number for me for growing up
yeah I'd love Mickey Mantle so he put me
in seven and Little League and I went to
Stanford and I wasn't a fool I was a
quarterback then I said you don't walk
into Stanford good so I went to 17 and
then I went to the league and I didn't
have a choice and they put me in 47 so I
like the number seven and hopefully
that's a good home yeah hopefully and
then hopefully for your sake you're in
your hotel room not just for that but
for for a game the day after the
announcement John I hope I hope only for
that for you that would be wonderful so
thanks to the call good luck we'll chat
down the line
thanks a lot rich I appreciate it right
back at you that's John Lynch 49ers
general manager and Pro Football Hall of
Fame finalist hoping we removed the word
finalist in a couple weeks right here in
the Rich Eisen show for more of the Rich
Eisen show tune - audience Channel - 39
unto rec TV for free on VR live or
download the Rich Eisen show app